here's the funny thing that we both have
like Broadway in common and yeah we've
both great well you you have like actual
Broadway I mean I just grew up in
musical food that you very different but
my point is is I remember my very first
musical and I was a little kid I was
like oh we're okay so we're just gonna
break out in song like like we were just
talking and then we're just gonna break
out song yeah baby come in then damn I
know but it's so awkward it's a
beautiful thing but I was like how
awkward is Hathi you just like go all
the sudden in song how can it be
[Music]
cheat me my last talented and longhua
sister my god show like the crazy thing
though about this movie it's a good
movie Scott Wolf's in it and it's dreamy
blue eyes and I wrote the title song for
it you'll love it oh what's the title
song caught a Christmas love story
hallmark oh my god that's so great
it all makes sense
[Music]
right
[Applause]
with the Tabernacle choirs a right of
Pat you need to do it you're older than
me let's just get it's gonna happen I'm
so how did you get involved they asked
me to do it so I finally took the
opportunity and I got to do I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this